[Music]
Sarah Paulson the gask of American
Horror Story Roanoke reunited for
PaleyFest in Los Angeles but before
their panel et caught up with the stars
on the red carpet and we had one burning
question for them what questions do you
still have from whatever season of
Horror Story what are you still dying to
know oh that's an interesting question
oh wow I can't even happen with the
aliens
season 2 what happened with that weird
monster that had a face like a vagina
do you remember that and I feel like
gave me bad face and it was weird but I
so I want to know what happened there
like what happened with the aliens where
did kit go does he live above us all now
with the vagina alien 9 aliens it's a
good question isn't it where is Jessica
and at the end of coven what is that
knotty pine place is that hell we're
actually usually financing naughty boy
and also where's misty day is she in
purgatory for you know dissecting that
Frog still and we have that sort of
rectified that would be good I had never
been in a series where when you read a
script and you die in it I thought I was
like but I died at the house so does
that mean is possible his ghosts spirits
I don't know and these are the things
that I thought about it I would like to
go back and visit Larry again a murder
house because lastly you about Larry he
was stuck in a jumpsuit in a prison
somewhere taking the fall for a crime he
didn't commit the magic of Cordelia we
never really got to see what all her
power was like when she was when she
actually became the supreme and how she
used her power and what power did to her
be sort of interesting also I hope I
could keep Cathy's head on a platter
that would be fun well my position in a
lot of fun to play
in Sydney that what I've just played in
Roenick was the most fun the camera
never stops no matter what anybody says
even if I tell you to stop you keep
rolling guy my stakes so high and why
like if somebody's changed lying their
head off behind me well I still like
keep going
Stanley is still alive somewhere in the
freakshow world he didn't die he was
mutilated did somebody feed him what if
I stay and look after Priscilla I fought
off the butcher twice I could do a much
better job of protecting her a couple of
fans were kind of upset by the ending
that I wasn't as a good mom for making
the choice that I made did I sacrifice
Oh was I being selfish so I guess that
was that was a new one for me I have to
kind of mold that over a little bit
[Music]